how are you determining which festivals
to submit to so with perfect 10 our
first feature that was a fact-finding
mission basically and we learned a lot
about really reading those RFPs and we
submitted to a lot of festivals that
just weren't a good fit and kind of a
not waste I we always think of it as as
we're donating to the cause of film by
our film film festival submission to me
don't get in I'm sorry just fully know
it's kind of like Kickstarter we're just
paying it forward so so through that so
I found some festivals through that just
going through the festival circuit the
first time and then we've met so many
people through that process and through
Twitter now and all the Tessa I now
pinpoint people like i asked paul
osborne what are your favorite festivals
you know i'm looking at other filmmakers
and where they play and what those times
you know and why are those your favorite
festivals are they because they're
filmmaker friendly is it because they
get you great press and great industry
connections and and then really calling
the list from that so and then finding
we have this type of film where is that
going to play better you know it's just
really asking every expert we feel you
know that's kind of done it what's your
favorite why and then kind of holding
the list from that not every favorite of
theirs is going to work but a couple of
them well and I throw them on the list
to give them a shot so it's just like we
just continually refine every time we go
I think we go through the festival
process of what what is just the better
and better list because I wasn't want to
be smart with our money yeah yeah I mean
it can get ridiculously expensive but
it's also you know we have to every
every film is going to have a different
festival release if that's the route to
choose to go you know it's like if we
made a science fiction film we'd be
targeting way different festivals and
we're targeting for the you know the
movie about marriage yep so yeah yeah
and to we also choose vessels sometimes
based on if we know people in the area
to make a cheaper to go with a lot of
front a lot of family in Sweden so we've
targeted some sweetened festivals which
you know a lot of international
festivals like Amir
because you know american progress their
international for their international so
um so we we choose like and we know our
colorist is from Australia so we he's
like these are the festivals in
Australia you want to their load these
great smaller festivals and I think you
have a good chance of getting into so we
were submitting to those and we know
someone there so when we go there like
for instance here we have a friend in la
we're saying you know in his apartment
and so it's free lodging which makes it
so we could be here the whole week so
it's I think just being really smart
about that and really reading and
researching going to the film but the
film festival's website and really
calling through what type of films are
they accepting and really at this am I
felt better don't be you know delusional
about I mean like for us like we had to
make the the decision you know looking
at some festivals looking at their list
like well if every film that they played
last year has a star in it that's not
gonna submit to them because we don't
have you know I mean they should be
stars but they're not yet so yeah
exactly yeah yeah so things just being
really smart about it and
really reading through it yeah
you